I got served some papers the other day I
mean a man came and served me
papers some of you guys know kai The
Hitchhiker
who is a notorious
um inner figure in entertainment I guess
um he's a homeless
uh or not homeless he's a vagabond he is
a uh Tumbleweed with a bit of violence
that surrounds him he filed a lawsuit
against me
for a tick tock clip that was put up our
Instagram clip
um that I didn't create that I shared
and uh I wanted to talk with um my buddy
Dan Morgan over at the Morgan Morgan
attorney firm
um
at the Morgan Morgan law firm and see uh
what the deal was so let's let's make
that call now if we can
hello this is Dan hey Dan man what's up
bud it's Theo
hey man what's going on uh well I sent
you you know I got served um I want to
talk about the kai the uh hitchhiker
thing
yeah yeah for sure I got those documents
so I reviewed them actually over the
weekend yeah man is so is it a real uh
is it a real thing like is it
I'm just I guess I'm kind of
I don't know you know I guess I'm scared
I'm yeah I'm scared about I don't know
what to do
it is real in the sense that he did file
it he did uh make some claims he's
currently incarcerated I believe in New
Jersey it seemed but it kind of learn
the law a little bit and drafted up this
complaint so it is an actual complaint
that they could served in federal court
um you know as far as the merits to it I
don't think there's much there I think
emotion uh to the submissive will kind
of cleaning up for you
okay
um so what do I uh how what is he asking
for
so he's making some some pretty
egregious claims in there I mean he goes
into all there's a lot of TMI really
about his other cases and his other his
other legal trouble that's going on but
then he pretty much does some type of
algebraic equation that that gets to a
demand request somewhere around 30
million dollars
I think it's around 20 29 750
000 something around those damages
from YouTube and Instagram views what do
I do
I must have to work I mean do I have to
work forever or what
I mean it sounds like he's claiming
you've already made this money so the
question is what have you done with all
that money
dude what is he talking about dude I
[__] have a I drive a Ford Ranger
he's saying you made all this money off
using this uh this deep fake of him
you've you've stolen his uh his Valor so
to speak I didn't make it his name
you're all good yeah he has this whole
outlandish theory that you have a a fake
identity daughter account where you made
this and then repurpose it because then
oh to then uh post on your YouTube and
without having to be the point person
that he could go after wow
it's like a 30 page Manifesto complaint
he he's he's doctored up from uh
so I'm just federal penitentiary
so is this so so what is when do I what
how long do when do I need to when do I
need to do something so it looks like
you got like a you served about eight
days ago or so like uh you got 21 days
per per federal civil procedure so you
know just just an answer pretty much
saying you know this is a bogus
also the motion to dismiss and a judge
should just just throw it out for you
but you do have to kind of make sure you
get those timelines done or else there
could be a default judgment where
old car could get a check from Theo for
30 million well he's never who's I don't
know where he even cash it yeah that's a
thing
I think he might take it
um okay so what do do you does uh does
y'all's Law Firm help with that or is
that something I need to do
that's something that I can help you get
get to the right person to do you know
we're we're more a plaintiff's type firm
we don't really do this defense work but
I can definitely get you the right hands
out there with California okay uh
federal attorney get this thing cleaned
up for you okay Jesus dude yeah I mean
um is this is this going to be like a
thing that happens in the world because
this was a uh deep fake that I didn't
have anything to do with I mean
obviously I repurposed it and put it out
and I think it I thought it was funny
and entertaining so I don't know if
there is some responsibility there I
don't know
exactly and when you kind of sent this
over to me I kind of started doing some
research and it's obviously a thing
that's popping up more and more now with
technology getting as it is and you just
really put in any video with any picture
and it turns it out but you know pretty
much it falls under some copyright
exceptions where where it's parity it's
an Ultimate Defense so
um you know it's art it's parody it's
not meant to be real you know there's
some protections out there especially
like political figures and revenge porn
stuff like that where there's been laws
that have been put put into place for
deep fakes but as far as you know this
type of stuff is really it's just parody
where where there's no real recourse or
damages that can be assessed for it wow
it's interesting because it that's gonna
I mean with with CGI and that sort of
this kind of thing if this is going to
be probably a growing field yeah
oh it's popping up yeah cause I mean
they got you know when the political
race is around they'll just take the
whatever party they don't like and just
have them saying some Outlanders you
know outlandish comments like you know
crazy stances and they put it out there
on YouTube and it gets retweeted and
they say you know it's become fact how I
mean how do we
what does the future hold
it I mean even now it's like it's I mean
the videos are getting better and better
that now they even have it where you can
type in
you know manifestos are lyrics and it
will spit it out in the person's voice
too so it doesn't even have to be a
recording them saying it's just you know
it's copying of their vocals now and
spitting it out yeah yeah we just been
talking about some of that recently that
chat GPT I think it's called and when
that merges with like Holograms or deep
fakes it's gonna get
I mean it's gonna get really strange you
know I I saw a thing a while back where
they had so much footage and um audio of
Joe Rogan that they could make him have
they could have audio of him now saying
absolutely almost anything in the world
oh exactly yeah and that that's how they
have all these politicians not to make
these speeches you know three speeches a
day they're just downloaded it all said
hey let's make them say you know listen
to like other like power started the
past it would take them you know years
to chop up something to have it even not
even something else you just type it
into a into a chat bot and it spits it
out in 30 seconds yeah man I mean all we
cared about was make them say
um
and it's just changed so much
um is this is this gonna be a field that
you guys will cover a lot uh at Shell's
Law Firm or is this
I mean if there was a if there was
damages against the natural plaintiff or
if there was some real harm that was
done and you know and something came
from it you would definitely look look
into it
um but as far as just these celebrities
having deep fakes made and stuff like
that you know it's probably something
we're going to stay away and just see
how the the law evolves around it amen
dude thanks so much man I appreciate it
bro it's definitely been spooky and yeah
the guy came up and served the papers
and I thought it was like a Jew like a
I don't want to say like a homeless dude
not home I mean he was like yeah they're
sneaky those process servers get sneaky
with it bro I thought it was like kind
of a game like kind of a dude who was
being kind of homoerotic or something
because he kind of just an audience but
it was hitting on you I mean he just
like kind of moseyed up I thought he'd
written me a poem or something and then
uh yeah and then he hit me with that and
he kind of like he didn't give like yeah
yeah it kind of like it was just I don't
know bro but I'm trying to meet a wife
gotta walked up boom it was just
surprising I'd never really been served
any papers I'd seen it happen a lot but
I'd never got them myself so it was
almost kind of nice dude and it was
almost like a valentine in a weird way
right yeah someone was thinking about
you yeah yeah that's true these days
that's nice uh Dan Morgan thanks so much
man I appreciate it brother
any time man I'm always a call away yeah
thank you so much dude I'll chat with
you soon
all right sounds good my man all right
peace if you have a question about a
legal issue you have a
um something that you think they might
be able to help with uh the least I can
do for that uh for the help there is
um to put their information uh below
you know it's scary it's scary when
something comes along or when uh there's
something in the legal realm and you
don't know what to do you know this that
can be spooky
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one